so while we have been doing a pretty
good job conserving water there's even
more we can do the legislature recently
passed ab-356
which prohibits the irrigation of
non-functional turf that you may see
lining the streets or medians in your
neighborhood all that grass will need to
be removed by the end of 2026.
continuing our team coverage sally
jaramillo is live in the southwest part
of the valley where homeowners there are
sharing some of their conservation
efforts sally
denise this area of town is booming with
a lot of new homes and people in this
area are finding ways to conserve new
homes like these people using low flow
showers and limiting shower times to
even leaving buckets inside their
showers
water conservation is incredibly
important it impacts our
our ability to
grow as a economy marcus johnson has
five people living in his home as well
as four dogs he is always finding ways
to conserve water i just purchased for
example a new internet connected
watering system and it only analyzes a
soil type but stops in wind and rain the
system will not only allow you to select
the days that you need but adjust easily
to ensure that
you're getting an optimal mix of water
as required johnson encourages his
grandchildren to take quick showers he
also checks on faucets and pipes for
leaks and only uses car washes i watch
it like a hawk
uh every build every build day you know
and ask hard questions about why is our
water up realtor rob pistone says every
home he's sold the past ten years does
not have grass a lot of people are on
board with saving water and you know
i've had a lot of clients with houses
that have a lot of lawns
and
number one they want to take it out to
save water pif lending ceo andrew levitt
agrees on purchases and refinances we
see a lot of people looking for some of
those newer homes that have a lot of the
features that will save water we've also
seen a lot of people doing cash out
refinances to get rid of the yards they
currently have
now some other recommendations update
your dishwashers and toilets get
tankless water heaters and of course
that desert landscaping is always a plus
and make sure you cover up your pool
reporting live sally jaramillo 8 news
now